[الموسيقى]
من
تحسين نظافة الأيدي في غانا
إلى الحفاظ على التباعد الاجتماعي في
بلجيكا
منحنية 19 ، طرحت العديد من التحديات الفريدة
في مشروع القرية هذا ماجي ، وهي
مؤسسة اجتماعية توفر
المياه المفلترة التي تعمل بالطاقة الشمسية للمجتمعات
منذ عام 2015. على الرغم من كون المياه موردًا محدودًا.
أدركت أهمية
غسل اليدين ومنع انتشار فيروس
كورونا وبدأت في تثقيف المجتمعات بشأن نظافة اليدين
وطوّرت اختراعًا بسيطًا وآمنًا ومنخفض التكلفة
لمساعدتهم على القيام بذلك ، ما توصلنا
إليه هو محطة لغسل الأيدي
حيث لدينا  تخلصنا من
أكبر نقطة ضعف في
محطة غسيل الأيدي التقليدية وهي
إغلاق الصنبور بعد غسل
يديك يدويًا ،
لذلك توصلنا إلى محطة تعمل بالقدم
يسهل
على القرويين صنعها وصيانتها
أكثر من 750 محطة لغسيل الأيدي
تسمى  تم نشر دلاء maji
وحملة توزيع الصابون
على 90 مجتمعًا في جميع أنحاء
غانا
مما أثر وفقًا لـ p  roject maji
حياة حوالي
75000 شخص
في مكان العمل هذا في أنتويرب
تسبب الحفاظ على التباعد الاجتماعي في تحديها الخاص في أطلس كوبكو ، حيث
كانت الشركة المصنعة للضواغط التي تحافظ على
سلامة ثلاثة آلاف
عاملاً أولوية قصوى ، وأهمها
بالطبع هو التأكد من أننا حافظنا على
مسافة  1.5 متر
في جميع الأوقات للعمل بطريقة آمنة
، لجأوا إلى شركة Lopos البلجيكية التي
صممت
جهازًا يمكن ارتداؤه لمسافة آمنة
يستخدم
أضواء الإنذارات والاهتزازات للتنبيه عندما
لا يتم احترام التباعد الاجتماعي ، وأعتقد أن
أهم شيء هو أننا قدمنا
التكنولوجيا التي يمكن تكوينها
حتى عندما تتغير اللوائح
الحكومية وهي ليست 1.5 ولكن ربما 2 متر
أو 1.3 ، يمكن لجميع عملائنا
فقط تكوين التكنولوجيا
والاستمرار في استخدامها
تقول لوبا إنها أرسلت 25000
جهازًا حتى
الآن أولئك الذين خلفهم  تُعد دلاء المسافة الآمنة و Maji
من بين عدد من المشاريع
التي اختارها برنامج إكسبو 2020 لأفضل
الممارسات العالمي
الذي سيُحدد  فرصة لعرض
ابتكاراتهم
خلال الفعالية التي استمرت ستة أشهر من أكتوبر
إليني جوهارس سي إن
دبي